et on en vient à la situation sanitaire
avec une épidémie qui flambe en europe
de l'est mais hier en russie il y a eu
mille 15 décès c'est un nombre jamais
atteint après saint pétersbourg moscou
annonce à présent des restrictions le
chef du kremlin devrait prendre de
nouvelles mesures aujourd'hui on fait le
point sur place avec notre correspondant
antoine cléroux
face à la flambée épidémique dramatique
qui sévit en russie les autorités
commence de nouveau à adopter des
mesures restrictives au niveau local
pour commencer à moscou il faudra
désormais qu'au moins 80% des employés
du secteur des services soient vaccinés
contre 60% auparavant les entreprises
devront faire en sorte de placer au
moins 30% de leur personnel en
télétravail les personnes âgées de plus
de 60 ans non vacciner devront quant à
elles se confiner du 25 octobre au 25
février prochain à saint pétersbourg
mais aussi dans d'autres régions on est
en train de mettre en place un système
de qr code qui concernera
progressivement salle de sport musée
cafés et restaurants au niveau national
d'autres mesures devraient voir le jour
comme l'expliquent la membre du
gouvernement en charge de la santé
a bâti bien reposé nous avons de nous
adresser au président de la fédération
de russie en vue de l'instauration de
jours chômés dans tout le paysage 30
octobre 2021 au 7 novembre 2021
cetin en parallèle pour les régions
présentant une situation épidémiologique
missive assange n'aurait pu prévoir la
possibilité d'instaurer des jours chômés
à partir de ce samedi 21 octobre 2021
dans le même temps il ne s'agit pas
seulement d'instaurer des jours chômés
mais également de l'instauration
simultanée d'un système de gestion de
l'accès à certains lieux pour les
personnes vaccinées ou ayant été
atteinte d'une colline 19 sur
présentation d'un qr code
depuis quelques jours il arrive à la
russie de dépasser le seuil fatidique
des 1000 décès quotidiens duo kobe 19
depuis des mois les autorités refusent
et de réintroduire des mesures
restrictives mais il semble que la
nouvelle envolée des contaminations
liées aux mauvais chiffres de la
vaccination les ai fait changer d'avis